chef rachel it has been a wild ride so
far season eight
how are you feeling about your debut
below deck season
well season great's been pretty awesome
i'm not gonna lie
this is uh a little whirlwind um i don't
know but
i think a thing called 2020 happened but
i pretty much
scanned past that really quickly um
other than that i mean it's been amazing
it's different
how did the show come your way obviously
you've been a yacht chef for a while but
how did they find you how did you find
them i think the rumor on the streets
was there's some crazy [ __ ] that cooks
on a boat
[Laughter]
eat my cooter
whoa you know you come on reality tv the
internet
is a treasure trove finds everything and
you know what's been recently unearthed
about you right
what that you auditioned for america's
next top model yeah that's that
that happened we actually had the clip
and i want to
watch you watch yourself from all those
years ago this was cycle four of uh
america's next
model
[Laughter]
so rachel why are you here why am i here
why not
you'd be representing more of a plus
size i'm down with that
my competition is everybody whether
they're
skinny and tall or voluptuous
and larger than me
look at that muffin top as long as i
ain't showing nipple
i'm good to go my grandparents are dead
i have no one to disgrace
i don't have to say anything look look
you got all the footage right there
i mean you've always been yeah you've
been rachel the whole time
i will tell you i just um got off with
kate and then josiah from
galleytalk and i also made them watch
that so rachel why are you here
why am i here why not you'd be
representing more of a plus size
i'm down with that my competition is
everybody
whether they're skinny and tall
or voluptuous and larger than me
anything that i can do i'll do it as
long as i ain't showing nipple
i'm good to go my grandparents are dead
i have no one to disgrace
i worked with rachel on yahta's cheese
too and
she was chef before below deck so i
already knew this about her
and um it's no surprise to me because
she really is gorgeous she's kind of
like a mix
between like a charlize theron she had
short hair at one point
and reese witherspoon like she's got
she's really stunning
and she's got personality plus i mean
she's hilarious she's one of the
smartest people i've ever met
um so i'm not surprised at all
both of your jaws dropped when um mr j
said you'd be representing the plus-size
market
here and i love how she didn't even
flinch she's like
sure like i i would have been like okay
i think well it's great to
basically get the job done no matter
what so she's like yeah that's what you
want me to do i'll do it
mm-hmm which is definitely
yeah exactly talk to me about that
experience why did you go out for top
model what was going on in your life at
that point in time
oh that was so much fun um i was
bartending
and the casting director came up to me
and thought you know
um excuse me have you ever thought about
being a bottle and i'm like
hi
i'm slinging drinks uh and i'm a kitchen
creature
so it wasn't like you know it was one of
those things they're just like hey you
know what i'm going to do
stand there and cattle call but it was
kind of cool like they just kind of
brought me through i think it had to do
with my personality being just awful
it was a lot of fun it was a lot of fun
tyra is interesting
like in the whole experience it kind of
you know gave me an idea of what
reality tv might become yeah a little a
little window in i guess your future you
didn't know
at that point though but okay so you
went in kind of no expectations like
sure i'll give this a shot but i don't
plan on sticking around
no no definitely not i actually wish
that we had cameras when
um i didn't make it to the next round
because then i got all the other girls
like because we're sequestered away in
the hotel room
and i had bottle service come and we
just got
wasted and we snuck out of the hotel
with my party downstairs
it was great